[Music]
I'm chef glor from CBS Saturday morning
welcome to the dish today we take an
inspired culinary Journey around Asian
Cuisine exploring authentic noodle
dishes from western China and the Bold
flavors of Thai in Filipino Fusion first
we start right here in New York City
with a taste of Korean food and the
culture it comes from our Dana Jacobson
is joined in the kitchen by New York
Times food columnist Eric Kim who's
written a cookbook on Korean home
cooking
foreign
as a cooking writer for the New York
Times food section Eric Kim's job is to
develop recipes delicious and accessible
for all kinds of cooks
do you cook much at home um not as much
as I should
[Laughter]
does it with dishes like sheep
bibimbap PB means mixed pop means rice
usually I do kale but I saw some really
great broccolini that was like kind of
flowering it's really pretty so I
figured we would do some broccoli action
his version includes assorted vegetables
that are chopped and oven roasted this
is the millennial version It's the
millennial version I would say let's go
a unique spin on the typically pan-fried
Korean staple it's a recipe he developed
when at 28 Kim left New York and moved
to Atlanta to live with his parents
while working on his cookbook I was
coming in and telling my mom
that I'm gonna do things a little
differently these are these very like
classic dishes you know and an idea like
the street campaign but she should kind
of be like I don't know like Koreans
don't do that but I was like I know but
we're Korean American so we can do what
we want we can do what we want
Kim is used to writing clear and
detailed instructions to make a meal and
wanted to specify what he calls his
mother's sonmot or her unique taste for
me my mom's food is immeasurable
but as a recipe writer I had to
approximate it at least get people like
a little clue with the measurement after
spending nearly a year in the kitchen
with his mom Jean the results of their
culinary Journey can be found in Kim's
first cookbook Korean American food that
tastes like home how joyful is it to
like to have a bite of food and be like
whoa never had that taste before right
speaking of which
here we go
take these out first
good job on those look at that
yes
eat as you go
the potatoes onions broccolini and
mushrooms are placed in quadrants over
the rice topped with a fried egg
drizzled with sesame oil it's art it's a
nice presentation it is right this is
what is going to flavor
The Whole Bowl the final step a choice
of gochujang a fermented chili paste or
dwenjang a soybean paste the final thing
there's no final thing that's it that's
it then you just have to eat it you just
mix it up
you go from this beautiful thing of
everything separated too yeah yeah
destroyed it's really just it's for you
it's like yeah
I love that it's fun right fun to eat
deviled eggs so for Kim korean-american
is more than a cookbook it's a journey
of discovery of the Korean cuisine he
grew up eating and of identity Kim's
parents immigrated to the U.S in the
1980s growing up in Atlanta he began
watching the Food Network as a teenager
eventually turning an interest into a
career for our dish Kim prepared Sesame
soy deviled eggs with black sesame seeds
a gem salad
and creamy bucatini pasta yes Mom cream
he crumbles Keem a roasted seaweed over
each one let's toss this
it's an all-purpose uh seasoner I
definitely use it I definitely use it
that way and I think some people would
be like okay enough with the Keem but um
for me it's like the flavor of my
childhood I really just you know
everyone has the thing that really takes
them back yeah they're pristine
Madeleine for me it's the taste of a
sesame oil salt and seaweed just like
the perfect trifecta flavors
an entire chapter in The cookbook is
devoted to kimchi I love these moments
like wow in the book an example of
Korean cuisine in which Kim says time is
the main ingredient that's what my mom
does she flips her Chopstick like this
and that means it's usually it's like
mixed noodles right for the table but
I'm gonna do it to give you one of these
okay but then there's also this this is
Napa cabbage okay so this is the one
we're probably like this is the one that
I knew always a lot of people are
familiar with yeah but they're different
kinds and they all have different
sweetnesses like different flavors and I
mean I'm gonna have some of this
what does your mom think of this
everyone kept asking me that I kept
forgetting to ask her I got her on stage
with me and of course she's really proud
she's always you know gonna someone
who's like proud of her children I've
also seen her light up a little bit you
know this this book really puts her
front and center and I'm also really
glad to highlight her Talent she's a
culinary artist like she's a really good
I think that's something that now people
get to taste Kim believes that true
talent in the kitchen means having
something to say with your food and he
says food has helped him Express his
true self what is Korean American to you
I actually had friends who who were like
maybe you should call it something more
that sounds more personal
um but for me nothing could be more
personal than these words and I think
it's because this book is
about my journey towards
accepting who I am just like as as I am
because when I started writing this book
I was terrified of what other Koreans
would think really because I think so
often
people see food or a recipe on the page
and they'll be like my mom doesn't do it
like that these flavors they always
hearken back to a memory I have a taste
a real thing it's not Fusion food this
is my life
oh
coming out the authentic noodles created
at this restaurant are some of the most
sought after in the nation we'll show
you next on the dish
[Music]
hand pulled noodles are very different
from what most of us are used to and a
lot harder to make than they appear we
met up with Chef Jason Wang of Xi'an
Famous Foods for a first-hand lesson
you already own it right hi guys coming
right up spend any time with Jason Wang
and his family and it's never going to
be long before you hear the sound of
slapping noodles
from this time-honored exercise emerges
some of the best comfort food you'll
ever consume
but before we get too far with the
demonstration the origin story when
Jason was just a small child his dad
David moved the family to the United
States from China
for years his father toiled as an
itinerant cook in kitchens all over the
Northeast he decided to open his own
restaurant people say hole in the wall
like it's a small restaurant but the
hole in the wall we're talking about is
a literal outside out like a little hole
on the sidewalk on the side of the
building next to the bus station
flushing the q58 your dad's out here
like documenting the whole time yes
documenting the process yeah she loves
it he loves to see you know
professionals at work it's fun it's fun
and he opened a place and didn't tell
you about it
he's a man of surprises the surprise of
his dad secretly opening a restaurant
became even more real for Wang not long
after as he writes in his book Shion
Famous Foods the cuisine of western
China from New York's favorite noodle
shop I joined the business in 2009 fresh
out of school I was you know now the
book is out basically I could stay I was
fired you know I was fired out of school
for my first job you know I was like oh
man life is over right but at the same
time I felt like maybe it was meant to
happen Jason went to work for his father
after his dad moved into a slightly
larger space before long there was
something about the family Dynamic and
the food that caught the eye of the late
Anthony Bourdain this place was
unbelievable this place is great
Bourdain showed up one day unannounced
to film an episode of his Show No
Reservations and loved it I've never had
anything like this before I mean I've
tasted these flavors but I've never had
this within the framework of Chinese
Xi'an named after the ancient Chinese
city was a hit even though many people
didn't understand and exactly what kind
of food they were eating people know
Beijing they know Shanghai Xi'an has
four million more people than New York
City and a lot of people don't know it's
there yeah I mean she has actually a
very important city in China it's
historically significant because that
city is the home of 13 dynasties of
Imperial China ancient China and there's
a lot of history there a lot of
landmarks and a lot of culture the famed
silk Rose started in Xi'an and the food
Wang serves as heavy on noodles not the
rice most people are used to seeing in
dishes from Southern China
the art of pulling and slapping noodles
can take a lifetime to master but it
only takes a few seconds to learn these
are our pieces of dough that we made
from just a big block of dough yeah it's
been made to the right consistency
covered with oil we're just gonna put a
Piece One Piece like this flat on the
surface there
we'll take the roller now you got these
skinny rollers work the best better than
those big you know bacon rollers
um so just not don't press too hard but
just kind of flatten it slightly so it's
like a big rectangle now and then just
indent the middle just slightly mine
looks like Massachusetts instead of a
rectangle it's a good steak
okay you're good all right so then just
take this piece off peel it off of the
board
grab the two sides but don't pinch too
hard like kind of like this
okay yeah just don't squeeze too hard
and start pulling it apart like this
when you get to be about shoulder width
or a little bit more you can start you
know using the board as a guide to kind
of slap it
so
it's gonna be more more in the uh
like the arms a little bit a little on
the wrist and you look much more Artful
doing this you know yeah table's a
little low but oh I just hit myself on
the phone that's part of the fun after
about three to five minutes in boiling
water hand ripped noodles are ready in
this case had to be served with a Shion
favorite spicy cumin lamb also dished up
for us stewed pork burgers a spicy Asian
salad with crunchy spiny cucumbers red
braised pork spare ribs and long pea
cold skin noodles ashion vegan favorite
all of these have attributed to our
Brand's success and I owe a lot of
gratitude to all of them there is one
catch with the Xi'an noodles you cannot
get them delivered now I tried to get
delivery
and you wouldn't do it I couldn't I
wanted to I okay I won't bring you cook
noodles Jeff there's I just can't do it
it's really
call me stubborn but I just cannot have
cooked noodles that it's gonna congeal
into this like doughy lasagna looking
mess and have that be the first
impression that you have with your
family you know I think that for me um
you know noodles don't travel after
10-15 minutes I wouldn't even eat it
myself I would throw it out
as a substitute these days Wang is
shipping out meal kits
so you can make the noodles fresh at
home
keep going
trust us it's fun
Sushi is considered a true art form in
Japanese culture where its appearance
and presentation is just as important as
how it tastes and it's really that first
aired on CBS Sunday Morning Lucy Kraft
looks at how fast food Sushi is
reimagining a dining tradition
when we stopped by last January shigosa
Sushi was still hanging out its cotton
shingle as it had for 85 years
beckoning the famished to a tiny counter
to Feast on delectable morsels gathered
at dawn from the seafood market
we take pride in our tuna Chef told us
we never serve frozen fish only fresh
chigosa was where locals savored a sense
of community as much as the handcrafted
jewels of salmon Roe and raw tuna how is
the sushi business changed over the
years
in the old days there were 30 Sushi
shops in this part of Tokyo he said now
we're the last one
eating chigos's lunch are brutally
efficient Mega chains like kudazushi
here customers seat themselves using
screens that operate by simply pointing
without actual contact next Patron scan
a digital code with their own
smartphones to download menus and order
food which is with to their table
paying via self-checkout customers
consume entire meals without ever coming
into contact with restaurant staff
has dumped the sedate etiquette of the
old Sushi counter for a raucous Carnival
with a shooting gallery prizes and an
endless series of games
less diners get bored Novelties like
cheesecake and onion rings are
constantly added to the menu
if this seems like the McDonald's of
sushi it's no accident
kudazushi which is launched in the U.S
aims to double in size to 1 000
locations by 2030. sales are higher than
before the pandemic
we aim to be on a par with global fast
food chains as spokesman hiroyuki
okamoto
even before coronavirus soaring fish
prices a Manpower shortage and
competition from the big chains had
wiped out more than half of traditional
sushi restaurants according to a
government survey and with most owners
at or near retirement the pandemic is
accelerating the demise of neighborhood
sushi
unrepentant the big Sushi chains argue
they are the true heirs to Japan's Sushi
tradition
back in the 19th century Sushi was sold
from outdoor stalls a cheap and filling
snack for the masses the chain spokesman
said we want to be accessible to
everyone so we charge just a dollar a
plate
handcrafted Sushi is becoming a luxury
offering dramatic decor and wine
pairings Sushi M places its Chef's
Center Stage some sushi chefs they
practice in the mirror to see what they
look like from the customer's
perspective food writer Melinda Joe
calls this performative Cuisine it's not
like the customer is always right as we
think in the U.S you are meant to enjoy
the piece of sushi exactly as the sushi
chef has intended it to be served
artisanal Sushi needless to say is
priced accordingly two hundred dollars
for the tasting menu at Sushi M I talked
to another food critic he was saying
we're going to see dirt cheap theme park
style discount volume places and then
we'll see the kind of place that we're
in right now which is catering to the
quote unquote one percent that's the
trend it's certainly something that
we're seeing already happening for most
Japanese sushi is becoming a commodity
not fashioned by Craftsman but cranked
out by a robot if everyone is only
eating at these kind of cheap sushi
places no one really starts to learn
about the beauty of the art form of
sushi
[Music]
that could use a little heat might be
heard now and then in the kitchen but
probably not this one after the break
the bright spicy flavors of Southeast
Asia up next on the dish
thank you
paying homage it's high in Filipino
Cuisines Chef Leah Cohen of New York
City's Pig and cow aspires to make Asian
fusion recipes accessible to home Cooks
I got a chance to sample some of the
amazing dishes and learn what inspired
her culinary Journey
it's coconuts time yes uh have you ever
made fresh coconut milk I have not okay
really I like using a Cleaver because it
has a nice weight to it and the exterior
of this coconut is very hard so you want
something heavy to kind of crack through
it there is nothing better than starting
a dish segment with coconuts and
Cleavers
so you
hard and it's going to start cracking
and but before we get too far with
homemade coconut milk Leah Cohen wants
us to know this cooking Thai food at
home or Southeast Asian food in general
does not have to be intimidating yes
they're often big very spicy flavors so
start with something simple like chicken
adobo every Filipino is judged on their
adobo whether it's a chicken or pork
every adobo has these five basic
ingredients soy sauce vinegar black
pepper garlic and bay leaves get a
little more adventurous and move to
papaya salad with long beans and dried
shrimp or mussels in a pineapple curry
broth never mind these ridiculous
ricotta Donuts it's not like super
traditional by any means they don't
normally have ricotta cheese in
Southeast Asia all of the dishes are
found in Cohen's homage to Southeast
Asian Cuisine lemongrass and lime
Cohen's mother is from the Philippines
but Leah's Ascension to Star Chef was
hardly preordained he grew up the
daughter of two dentists yeah
[Laughter]
when the the doctor dentist route aside
from me and my brother but there are
like I want to say like 10 dentists in
the family it was definitely
um the path less chosen being a chef no
one in my family it really was a
professional cook my grandmother was a
home economics teacher so I guess that's
kind of maybe where I got you know the
cooking bug why Southeast Asian Cuisine
for you I just found the food so
fascinating and the flavors so bold and
uh intimidating at the same time I felt
connected to that part of the world I
like the way you talk about breakfast in
the book yeah and that it's such a
different there's Breakfast such a
different Concept in Southeast Asia than
it is here there are
you would necessarily eat just for
breakfast like we think of cereal and
all that stuff but in the Philippines
for example they eat like rice dried
fish a soup there is no real rules
necessarily for breakfast although I
tried to make more breakfasty brunchy
items for that chapter also in the book
lumpia Shanghai Olympia lumpia yeah and
I'm dipping this in this is a sweet
chili sauce so it's a little sweet
Savory it's not spicy at all
perfect thank you and the Bangkok fire
made with chili infused whiskey Cheers
Cheers
oh yeah that does have heat but for the
moment back to the Coconuts when you
pick one you want it to feel heavy that
means that there is a lot of liquid
inside and that will make more coconut
milk coconut milk sounded great to us so
Cohen I think you can do it let us take
a whack at it yeah
oh Perfect You're a pro look at that see
it felt aggressive yeah it's a good way
to get your anger out I think in a good
way yeah totally it's therapeutic you
know Cohen's hopes her cookbook will
inspire people to make some outside of
the box creations at home that they
might not try otherwise
though for Cohen this accomplishment is
Bittersweet I was really struck by the
dedication in your book yeah so
unfortunately
um I lost my father to covid and so I
was able just in time to change my
dedication because originally it was
dedicated to my son but my father was my
biggest fan and so I wanted to make sure
that everyone knew how proud I was of
him just like they knew how proud he was
of me so when you talk about his
unconditional love Yeah he was probably
the most positive person I've ever met
he like knew the secret to life he
really just enjoyed life he knew how to
push people to do great things without
being overly uh annoying and on top of
you
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Jeff glor
we'll see you next time for another
helping of the dish
[Music]